combien seront ils à rester ou à venir à
montréal cet été
c'est la grande question qui inquiète
l'industrie touristique de la ville sans
grands festivals concerts en plein air
et feu d'artifice la belle saison sera
beaucoup moins flamboyante
au vieux pas en droit le plus visité au
québec avec plus de 6 millions de
touristes par année
c'était très calme lundi midi les rares
piétons rencontrés étaient montréalais
ça fait deux ans que j'habite ici c'est
toujours animé ça fait quand même une
grande différence sur l'été à montréal
vous l'imaginez commun je n'imagine
surtout à l'extérieur de montréal
nous on fait balconville on reste ici on
se promène au vieux port ce projet faute
d'aller se divertir à l'étranger les
québécois pourront se rabattre sur les
offres touristiques de montréal qui
commencent à rouvrir
c'est le cas au vieux port qui est
ouvert en ce moment avec un voile envoie
la tyrolienne
les pédalos les fameux kadri sec
d'autres attractions comme la grande
roue ou le grand labyrinthe attend
toujours l'aval du gouvernement pour
accueillir des visiteurs
on sent parfois le découragement les
groupes s'est déjà passé c'était toutes
été annulées et remboursées les
touristes c'est quand même une portion
importante de l'achalandage
mais où est ce que je reste très positif
c'est que on était encore de morgan et
montre encore du monde qui aime la vie
aimait la vie
mais avec beaucoup moins de manière d'en
profiter ces jours ci le casino de
montréal est fermé jusqu'à nouvel ordre
tout comme le centre des sciences ou les
expositions implique beaucoup de
manipulations on travaille très très
fort en ce moment pour en prendre et
ouverture et on espère être en mesure
d'ouvrir cet été dans les prochaines
semaines mais c'est un défi important
défi important aussi pour la ronde
toujours déserte
le parc d'attractions attend encore
l'autorisation des autorités pour ouvrir
quand il le fera les places seront
limitées et il faudra réserver sa date
de visites sur le web
dans l'est espace pour la vie ne sera
pas très vivant cet été le jardin
botanique et déjà ouverts mais les
places y sont limitées et là aussi il
vaut mieux réserver le planétarium est
encore fermée tout comme le biodôme et
l'insectarium qui eux sont en
réaménagement et n'ouvriront pas de
l'été oublier aussi le funiculaire du
stade pour le reste de l'année
il n'y aura pas non plus d'événements
sur l'esplanade ni de matchs de l'impact
devant public au stade saputo
malgré tout le président de tourisme
montréal demeure positif c'est quand
même mais le parc sont à montréal des
quartiers qui sont fantastiques et
visiter on dit montréal ça se visite pas
ça se vit ensuite de se les musées sont
ouverts tu peux voyager à travers les
musées également les centres commerciaux
vancouver également pour le magasinage
et à des restaurants qui sont d'une
qualité fantastique à montréal on pourra
visiter l'oratoire saint-joseph à partir
du 29 juin
la plage du quai de l'horloge ouvrira le
3 juillet et sera gratuite l'ouverture
de la plage de l'île notre dame
elle est prévue à la mi-juillet les
excursions en bateau devrait aussi
reprendre bientôt
alors que le cosmodôme de laval est déjà
ouvert
marc antoine vacheron et spécialiste en
tourisme ce que vous seriez tenté
d'aller visiter
oui oui
en planifiant plus qu'à l'habitude on
peut voir le verre à moitié vide ou à
moitié plein il ya quand même des trucs
qui montre particuliers qui vont être
tafer spécifie qualité qu'on revit
aujourd'hui je pense aux terrasses je
pense à plusieurs rixes ont piétonnière
voici d'ailleurs des photos prises hier
soir sur mont-royal et bernard toutes
deux fermées aux voitures
ces corridors sanitaires devraient faire
des terrasses un grand attrait de
montréal cet été mais il ajoute au
casse-tête routier c'est plus qu'une
épine dans le pied en fait c'est un coup
de poignard est ce que vraiment la
clientèle
montréalaise va venir dans le vieux
montréal avec tous les obstacles de
circulation qu'il y a plein que la
circulation y en aura - dans le cas des
entraves du côté des cônes orange si
vous voulez qu'ils auront à se tenir en
mai prochain la ville samo dernier ce
que ce soit plus belle
voilà on est prêt pour la saison en
attendant montréal invite les québécois
à venir faire un tour
consciente que l'été sera différent mais
convaincu qu'elle pourra les charmes et
malgré tout ici jean-sébastien cloutier
radio canada montréal